-Our first guest tonight i
an Academy Award-nominated actor
you know from films like
"Batman,"
"Birdman" and "Spotlight."
You can see him in
"The Trial of the Chicago 7,
which is available
on Netflix now.
Let's take a look.
-Hey, Bill.
Ramsey Clark.
-Pleased to meet you, sir.
This is Leonard Weinglass.
-Mr. Weinglass.
-And Tom Hayden.
-Oh, I know who Tom Hayden is.
The FBI used to work for me.
Those two men
are senior deputies
with the Justice Department.
That's Mr. Calley
and Mr. Ackerman.
-Well, I don't know why
these men are here.
-I invited them.
-You invited them?
-I don't want the appearance
of impropriety.
-There isn't any impropriety
-And now there
are witnesses to that.
-Please welcome back
to the show
one of our favorites,
Michael Keaton.
How are you, Michael?
-Hey, man.
How are you doing?
-I'm good.
You know, it's --
-Before we start, just be fair
-[ Laughs ] Okay.
You know what?
I'm glad you said that.
Because these were going to be
real tough ones.
[ Laughter ]
-Round the corner,
round the corner and be fair
Sorry, I have this on.
I just went out for a minute
Look at this.
I want to show you something
-Great, I can't wait.
-Speaking of being fair,
can you see that?
-Yeah, look at that.
-Yeah, but look at you,
speaking -- Wait, wait.
How do I do this?
-The other way, the other way.
What are you trying to show me
-I'm trying to say look at you
speaking of being fair,
you're trying to hypnotize me.
-[ Laughs ]
-Look, look at you, man.
Some kind of
Spock hand gesture.
-It's been really --
I should say,
it's a great disadvantage
because I'm having no luck
hypnotizing over Zoom, nothing
-Man, tuna fish,
half a tuna fish
salad sandwich in a briefcase.
Oh, man, that's funny.
Oh, man, that's good.
That's strong.
-Thank you, Michael.
-This is odd to do --
By the way, can I say this
-Yeah.
-This is odd to do --
Look at those hands, by the way.
That's just way too much.
-[ Laughs ]
-In the afternoon,
it feels funny.
It feels like this show
should be at night.
-I know.
-So I had to get some coffee
to kind of wake up a little bit.
-I mean, you're coming off
as a guy who is fully awake.
-Oh, good. Oh, good.
[ Laughter ]
Good.
That's the standard.
"Yeah, he looked awake."
-Hey, I want
to talk about --
-This barista -- barista?
-Yeah, yeah, that's it.
-Yeah, yeah.
So, I went and she was --
Yeah, I was wearing this.
And I'm very cautious out there,
so I ventured out
to get some coffee.
And she was really perky, like
way too perky for me
and really loud
when she took my order.
And there was a plexiglass thing
in the front and everything.
She was nice enough,
but she kept going "Hi!"
Like, "Hi!"
And she kept saying,
"What's your name?
What's your name?"
Kind of like one of Santa'
helpers would say it.
You know, "What's your name?
And it freaked --
and I'm kind of --
when I'm out there, I'm very -
you could just see, like,
the COVID splashing against --
[ Laughter ]
It was just
hitting the plexiglass.
You just want to walk out.
Anyway, it made me very,
very nervous.
But you know what?
We're good because we've got
Scott Atlas on top of it.
-[ Laughs ] That's true.
Everything is under control.
-Is that not the greatest name
Does that not sound like -
the only thing better
than Scott Atlas would
have been like Johnny Atlas.
But Scott Atlas sounds
like a teen star
from the '80s, doesn't he?
-Yeah, it's like they gave Trump
a list of doctors
and he just picked the nam
that sounded
like the coolest-looking dude.
-Yeah.
"Hi, I'm Scott.
Hey, gang, I'm Scott Atlas
I'll be at the Fairhaven Mal
this week
promoting my new album."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God. The girls are going
crazy for Scott Atlas.
They're lined around the block
Hey, this movie is so great.
And it's an Aaron Sorkin script.
-Yep.
-And I have to imagine
as an actor,
there are just certain writers
where it's just a delight
to do their dialogue.
And not only do you
get to do Sorkin dialogue,
you get to do Sorkin
courtroom dialogue,
which is maybe --
-Yeah.
-Maybe his highest tier.
-That's right. That's right.
That's right.
That is -- That's a bump up.
And you know what else?
If you watch --
First of all, this cast
in this movie is so good.
But if you noticed,
that's exactly right.
When you get in the courtroo
or anything like that,
it actually bumps up.
When you watch this movie
and what he does is,
you'll be right
in the long stretch
of a dramatic,
tension-filled scene.
And he'll just drop a gem
of a joke, a gem of a funny line
and kind of, you know, boop,
lifts everything up from it.
He was really fun to work with
It's a really,
really terrific movie, I think
-I do want to --
because again
there's this scene
in the courtroom.
And as an actor, like,
is it thrilling or intimidating?
I mean, just the people that are
watching you do your thing
like, Frank Langella,
Joseph Gordon-Levitt,
Mark Rylance, Sacha Baron Cohen,
Jeremy Strong.
I know I'm leaving people out.
-Eddie Redmayne.
-Does it make more fun or even
after doing this
a long time you're like,
"Oh, there's some real
A-listers here?"
-You know, absolutely.
That's a great question.
Absolutely, it makes it
more fun now.
You want to be in that.
It's like playing
pickup basketball.
You know?
When you say, "Yeah,
I'll go down to the park
and play a little bit."
But the whole rhythm
of everything,
when everybody is so much better
or so good around you.
The only thing that happened
when I did the first "Batman,"
was I was very --
I was pretty nervous
and self-conscious
about being with Jack.
-Sure, sure.
-Because he's so strong
on film, you know?
And it ended up
just being great, you know
Just being great.
We became pals and everything.
But yeah, that's
a good question.
It felt pretty good actually
-Do you think, like,
when you think back to "Batman,"
and you saying that,
of course it makes sense.
Do you think Jack Nicholson then
and throughout his career,
and certainly at that poin
of his career,
do you think he was aware
that people would be,
you know, intimidated
to work with him?
Did he have to go out of his way
to be disarming?
-That's --
You know, I don't know.
I don't know that I've eve
thought of it like that.
That's a great --
That's a great question.
I would say, yeah,
he probably --
he probably was pretty aware
of his power.
He was so -- He had so muc
power on screen, you know, has
But it was just cool.
You know, he made everybody feel
really, really relaxed.
You know?
Someday in private I'll tell you
how he would greet
the crew in the morning.
[ Laughter ]
Certainly can't do it
on national television.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, by the way,
your pop's name is Larry, right?
-Yeah, Larry.
-Hey, Larry.
-There we go. Now I'm glad
we're gonna finish with this
-They're back, baby.
-He'll be very happy.
5-0. We got the 5-0 Steelers
against, I think --
I guess, the 5-0 Titans.
How are you feeling about
the Steelers this season?
-Great so far.
-Yeah.
-I mean, this is fun so far.
We'll see.
But, you know, I'm a fan of al
those teams -- Pittsburgh teams.
-And I know you've been
tweeting a lot
about Pennsylvania politics.
And, you know,
we were mentioning Obama
was there yesterday.
-Yeah.
-I know you were really
politically engaged
as a kid thanks to your parents.
Your dad -- everybody is talking
about having a plan for voting
Your dad gave you
a very specific plan
when you were voting.
-Yes, yes.
My dad was commissioner
for a while.
He was very involved locally
You know, he's a working
man's Democrat.
And it was -- So it was always
in my consciousness.
And just to show you
how important it is to vote,
I grew up between two
kind of tough little mill towns,
you know, Coraopolis
and McKees Rocks, and --
but in the center it was rural
We were kind of country kids
So it was small.
The population was small
in the township.
And my dad, when it became legal
to vote at 18,
I could not wait to vote.
But my dad [Laughs]
told us how to vote.
He said, "Okay, now's here's
who you vote for
in the election today."
So I go, "Okay."
And he told me.
And I went, "Yeah, alright
that all sounds reasonable."
So I go to the polls.
There was no line or anything.
This was a smaller town.
I go, "Check, check,
check, check, check."
And then it comes to --
I don't remember who it was,
water commissioner or something.
And I go, "Who did he say
to vote for?
I can't remember.
I'll just leave that blank."
So I go tell my sister, Pam.
I go,
"Hey, Pam, who was I
supposed to vote for?"
Because I couldn't remember,
and she told me.
And I went, "Well, I don't know.
I just left it blank."
My hand to God, this is true
We're sitting at
the dinner table.
And there's conversation,
and my dad goes,
"How about --"
I'll say Mary Smith.
I don't remember.
"How about Mary Smith
losing by one vote like that
[ Laughter ]
[ Bleep ]
I swear to God.
I looked across the table
at my sister
and she just, like, put her head
down and kept eating.
[ Laughter ]
So vote.
-Well, that is a good reminder
for everybody
to remember to have a plan
on Election Day,
because it can all fall apart.
-Hey, man.
-There we go. It's upside down
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
It's a sign.
-Michael Keaton
tells you to etov.
[ Laughter ]
-That's code.
That's code for something.
-Oh, gotcha.
I'm sorry.
I didn't realize.
Hey, thanks for being here
buddy.
I really hope
next time in person.
-Thanks, man.
-You can tell me
what Jack Nicholson said.
That is Michael Keaton.
-I will.
-"The Trial of the Chicago 7
is available on Netflix now.